contrairement aux apparences
yao n'est pas cascadeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à pitre
offert par israël
ça donne quoi
poussins tout ça
les assistants comme yao sont payés pour
contrôler les billets charger les
bagages mais aussi distraire les clients
avec des acrobaties spectaculaires
car un passager qui ne s'ennuie pas est
un passager qui reviendra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les salles de bains
boisé fois
leur numéro d'équilibriste est inspiré
d'une danse de combat pratiqué dans les
quartiers
il y a plusieurs figures imposées
la banane
[Musique]
samu dans le forez
en tant qu'assistant il gagne 1 euro 50
par jour ce n'est pas grand chose mais
comme ils le disent ses shoots
d'adrénaline compensent leurs petits
salaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'énergie de la jeunesse ivoirienne
porte le pays vers le haut
elle en a fait le premier producteur au
monde de cacao de noix de cajou
sans compter le coton et bien d'autres
la côte d'ivoire est devenue le pays le
plus riche d'afrique de l'ouest
des titres de gloire aux allures de
médaille en chocolat
à
c'est le bonheur ils ont fermé la tour
ce n'est pas pour rien et pousse
mr
d'une ville à l'autre est encore une
aventure pour les ivoiriens
[Musique]
le pays ne compte plus les morts
provoquées par des engins à fiston
ils nous voient sous des sudokus police
basque on n'a pas de moyens trouver le
nouveau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cours du cacao c'est rythme
l'économie du pays alors quand ils
chutent la côte d'ivoire sous ma bêtise
ces accords de travail
voit dans la télévision voire des wade
s'est repris mais nous n'arrivons
craignant pour endiguer la pauvreté le
pays s'industrialise mais la modernité
n'a pas encore atteint les crampons aux
pieds des cas c'est un problème
alors certains cherchent leur richesse à
coups de pioche
c'est en fait son travail du et en
equateur -
[Musique]
m
tous là sauf a été comme ça
mais à moins d'un an
le défi des ivoiriens est immense mais
la volonté de ses habitants est encore
plus grande